déjà qu'est-ce que tu ressens quand tu
sors de cette émission en 2017 c'est
marrant je me rends pas compte de ce que
j'ai vécu ça veut dire je sors et je me
dis bon
ok ils sont allés un peu plus fort que
ce que je pensais mais tu sais j'avais
pas d'attente très positive quoi
naïvement en fait puis je me rendais pas
aussi non plus trop compte de ce que je
m'étais pris dans la gueule en fait pu
c'estune fois que c'est sorti et que les
gens eux se sont s'en sont rendus compte
avec le recul que moi aussi je m'en suis
rendu compte j'étais en mode mais c'est
vrai c'est vrai qu'en fait ils
ont pas été très gentils au final c'est
quoi à ce momentlà ce qui a Roché dans
cet extrait c'est une forme de c'est une
forme de mépris c'est une forme
d'incompréhension c'est les deux faut
aussi avoir du recul sur ce qu'on fait
évidemment que quand tu fais des lives
sur les jeux vidéos twitch et que tu
gagnes de l'argent comme ça bah pour des
tas de gens c'est hyper flou ils se
disent mais attends du coup tu es juste
payé pour jouer donc tu vois il y a
quand même des des trucs où je comprends
et d'autres trucs où tu dis non là il a
là il y a quand même une intention de
tourner en ridicule ou de nuire les
ambassadeurs un peu de ces nouveaux
médias et donc en fait quand tu te fous
de ma gueule comme ça en plateau en
réalité tu te fous de la gueule d'une
passion que des millions de gens ils ont